hey i'm kevin hi i'm evie's best friend
brian hi
i'm looking for a new best friend my
name is evie ouch
i am not getting into that today we're
going to be drawing
a stranger based only on their voice and
description
all right so it is time for our stranger
to join us stranger could you please
tell us your name
hello guys my name is karina hi
hi karina guys karina where are you
coming from
i'm from brazil wow brazil
that's so far away and karina how did
you get to be on the show today
well i posted a video on instagram i saw
your post
asking for people to participate of the
show and you were chosen
yeah chosen ones it was a really
surprise
karina have you ever met any of us
before yes i actually
saw the videos from the draw off but we
haven't met in person
no all right so here's how it works
karina can't see our screens we can't
see each other's screens
so the only way we know what to draw is
by what cutting that tells us and if
you're drawing at home
be sure to tag us on instagram and
twitter at drawoff show
everybody ready yep yes all right let's
do it
so karina first things first please tell
us
your pronouns and your ethnicity well
i am shi and i have portuguese
italians russians germans wow
okay yes mixed babies did i say spanish
and spanish
my gosh it's a mess guys i'm brazilian
guys that's
why you get here in brazil karina if
your face
was closest to a fruit what would you
say your face shape is like
i would say an apple okay because it's
a big circle
so while we're drawing karina tell us
about your
your history were you born and raised in
the town you're in
yes i actually lived near my mother's
house so
i live in the same place of the city
that i was born and raised what were
some things that you did when you were
growing up
well i always play it at video games
when i was a kid i like to play
crash crash thank you yes
it was one of my favorites nowadays i
play league of legends
i play league of legends 2012 me and my
husband
wow what are you actually we played
together since we were kids
i became best friends because we used to
play together
we met each other on the church okay
and we both played a game called harvest
moves oh
oh my god we became friends because of
it we were eight years old
oh my god that's horrible
[Music]
everybody stop this isn't a good
i didn't know that i needed to bring
tissues for this too
starting over how do you guys do this
yeah you just gotta you just gotta
pick it up go with it yeah yeah right
you're right
gotta keep going when i hopped on today
i was like i hope i remember how to draw
i say that to myself every morning every
day karina are you an artist
actually i'm a lawyer you're a lawyer
wow
but one i have a lot of
hobbies like my husband and i we used to
play in the same band together
he plays bass and i play the piano
keyboard
you guys are the coolest couples what
don't you two do
i like reading i like embroidering and
eating
oh my gosh some people think i'm
teenager some others think that i'm an
old lady
you do have a very young sounding voice
when i have a new class
in this school that i teach english
people think that i'm one of the
students
but nowadays i i don't teach very much i
only have one class because i started
practicing law you just decided to
switch things up start practicing law
yeah you know like these are fun yeah
you pick up embroidery
pick up the piano in a few months she'll
just be doing our job
yeah i'm an artist now and i'm better
than all of you
no i like a drawing but i'm not very
good on this well we're not either yeah
so
yeah i'm here again you're great
um what actress would you say people
liking you too
people normally don't compare me to any
actress but
about my mouth they compare her to
angelino's mouth oh
i can picture that do you have a
favorite cartoon actually my new
favorite cartoon is a brazilian cartoon
jordael's brother
it's from cartoon network i like it very
much because
this story has a lot of brazilian
culture
cool but before i watch this
show gravity falls oh yes
my cat's name is mabel oh cute
i really like maple because i really
like her
actually my hair looks like her too all
right
wait what go oh there we go
so kareena uh it sounds like you and
your husband
are very busy is there anything else you
do
yeah actually we run a restaurant what
oh come on get out done i'm done i'm out
of here
seriously that's not fair
it's a pastel restaurant it's a
brazilian dish
i need to lie down wait what what's in
this dish
it's a dough that we fry this dough
and it has some stuffing inside of it
is it more like a fast food oh
and i just answered the phone why don't
cook
i'm not this talented okay
that's one thing you don't do okay of
all the things you do karina what's your
favorite
my favorite i guess that it's teaching
that's why i didn't stop oh that's
awesome do you have any particular
accessories that you want us to include
yes glasses glasses would be good
glasses gamer
all right very quickly i have to add
glasses to this before i do my color
it's two circles real fast
maybe for you so karina when this
episode
is done and on the internet what are you
gonna do
well i will definitely post on my
instagram
and i really want to show the episode
for my students
because they like you very much
might help them learn conversational
english too huh yeah
oh no don't teach them english based off
a draw
we know all the best english we are an
english learning channel no
we're not second second entertainment
there's a
distant distance okay
depends now how do you think you did i
think
i did probably it's gonna be the best
one
wow okay i think it's a bold statement i
think mine is
second best to brent's well then that
makes mine the worst i'm just kidding
kevin
is not i have no idea how well i should
all right everyone let's send these to
each other and we're going to send them
to you karina to see
how we did okay
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
they're actually kind of closed
i love that one of them shows me working
and the other one is like how i would
wear
in my day-by-day life casual yeah i took
that apple
head shape to heart very accurate karina
your voice
sounds very young and so i i tried to
keep you
uh young about the face yeah i'm 26.
you sound much younger yeah well i was
trying to think like
those pouty angelina jolie lips really
stuck with me when you said that you
would like dress up as mabel or you had
like um a lot of cartoon t-shirts
so i tried to put mabel's little
shooting star
tonight i actually have a t-shirt with
this shooting
the shooting star from label all right
it is time for the big reveal
and if you're playing along at home be
sure to pause here
finish your drawing so you don't see
what carina looks like
before you're done all right karina are
you ready yes i am
so i'm going to count three two one
hi guys oh hey
there you are here am i oh my gosh
it's so nice to see you it's nice to see
your face
it's nice to see you too i feel like
abby might be the most stack
yeah i think i think eddie i think you
got the closest yeah
all right all right well karina thank
you very much for joining us thank you
for being our stranger today we all had
a
wonderful time drawing you thanks i
loved it for a better look at these
drawings your drawings and the chance to
find out how you could become
our next stranger be sure to follow us
on instagram or twitter
at drawoffshow and we'll see you next
time okay
ciao ciao
i think it's going to be very tricky
drawing me
because as you can see i'm not that hot
brazilian girls that you guys are used
to seeing the movies
i kind of have this baby full of cheeks
face